a campaigning for the United Kingdom's
election next month is officially
underway voters will elect a new
Parliament on December the 12th the
outgoing Parliament was formally
dissolved earlier in the morning before
Prime Minister Boris Johnson went to
Buckingham Palace to notify Queen
Elizabeth of the steppe Labour leader
Jeremy Corbyn has kicked off his party's
campaign speeches in a series of
constituency's brexit is likely to
dominate the election campaign but
candidates will also focus on health
care climate change and other issues
now d-double is Charlotte paths and
joins me now from London she's tracking
that story welcome Charlotte so what can
we expect from Boris Johnson and the
Conservatives or what's become very
clear this morning is that it is going
to be a very nasty campaign Boris
Johnson the Prime Minister compared his
opposition leader Jeremy Corbyn with the
dictator with a Soviet dictator Joseph
Stalin so this is the kind of language
he will use in the upcoming campaign and
he is also trying to paint a picture of
this election as people versus
Parliament she said right now in his
campaign launch speech that he that this
Parliament didn't get anything done on
brexit that that needed to change and
that only was him in power brexit would
get done and the United Kingdom could
move on from this brexit saga so this is
a clear strategy behind his election
campaign vote for me and then we get
brexit done and what about the
opposition Charlotte what are they going
to be saying and doing to try and get
votes in their favor well also they are
painting a very nasty campaign at the
moment Jeremy Corbyn I was at his
campaign launch at the Labor campaign
launch last week and he is making this
election about people versus the elite
going against in his words dodgy
landlords billionaires
tax evaders those kinds of people and he
is trying to make this election about
domestic issues about health care and
housing because his message on brexit is
not very clear the latest message on
brexit is not very clear they demand a
second referendum but Jeremy Corbyn
won't say where he stands on the issue
so it's much more complicated than on
the conservative side and this is what
could cost them some voters in the end
and I know it's early days but given
recent opinion polls is it possible to
speculate on the outcome of the election
well at the moment when you look at the
polls it looks very good for the
conservatives that they would get a
majority in parliament but of course the
campaign of the conservatives has start
has quite has had quite a shaky start
for example was it Joseph Stalin
comparison that the Prime Minister drew
this morning and five weeks until the
election of course is a long time to go
and what will be really interesting to
see is how voters will react to the
fringe parties for example the brexit
party who wants to get brexit done ASAP
and the Liberal Democrats on the other
side who want to forget about brexit
altogether and stay in the European
Union so there we will keep a close eye
on those parties of course but what is
very clear is that this general election
is all about brexit 80% of voters say
they will make up their mind in regards
to the issue so we can expect another
so-called well referendum on the issue
of brexit in this general election right
referendum to the ballot box
Charlotte Potts thank you very much for
that update from London